the education secretary left downing
street with a wave
but offered no comment on what was
decided during a key meeting with the
prime minister
for now the government insists its plan
for a staggered return for secondary
school pupils
remains unchanged teachers and head
teachers have been working incredibly
hard
um you know over the christmas period
since schools uh broke up
in order to prepare for a new testing
regime community testing
in order to make sure that the children
and all of us are safer
so we do keep things under review but
that is the plan
under current plans primary school
pupils in england will return as normal
while the majority of secondary school
pupils will be taught remotely as mass
testing plans are put in place but with
concerns growing that the new variant of
kovind 19 has changed the balance of
risks
one of the largest teaching unions is
calling for a rethink
delaying the start date for schools is
only one of a number of options that the
government needs to be considering but
so far
we're not hearing any options from the
government
events have overtaken us they've
overtaken the government
and we're saying that the government now
needs to catch up with her
and actually bring that clarity to bear
with a week to go before the start of
the new term
the government is under pressure to
announce any changes as quickly as
possible
boris johnson has previously said that
keeping schools open
is a national priority and back in the
summer
that position received the endorsement
of the chief medical officer
who said many more children were likely
to come to harm by not going to school
than going to school even in the midst
of a pandemic
but the big question that remains
unanswered by the government
is whether that assessment remains the
position
of its scientific advisors labor say
that even if the plan remains the same
ministers need to be open about the
advice being presented to them it's
absolutely vital
that the government today makes that
scientific advice publicly available
and that the prime minister and his
scientific advisors come and
make the position clear too to parents
and to school staff
because this kind of rumor and innuendo
is just really really worrying for
everyone
in west london this afternoon that worry
was evident
it's really hard i'm a full-time working
mum as is
my husband works full-time so
i love them but i don't want them home
and it's important that
you know just the right decision is made
for public health reasons
but obviously yeah we prefer to have the
kids at school and we think that's
important
for their development that's the concern
of the chairman of the education select
committee
who's urged the government to recognise
the long-term impact school closures
could have
there are two risks there's a risk of
covid which you have to do everything to
try and
protect people from but also there is a
risk of
of establishing it or an epidemic of
educational
poverty making it endemic in our country
as head teachers in england prepare for
the start of term next week
they will be doing so against a backdrop
of growing uncertainty
over what kind of schooling they're
preparing for
tom rayner sky news westminster